hi there everyone this is a quick video
or non-video about the discovery or
non-discovery of the higgs boson so a
lot of 60 symbols viewers have been in
touch asking are we going to make a
video about today's news and the answer
is of course yes
but unfortunately i can't make it today
that's because i'm here
on top of a volcano
on the island of la palma
one of the world's most famous
observatories up here and of course that
makes it difficult for me to speak to
the people at the university of
nottingham about the higgs boson
but i have been in touch with him on
email and they've said we're going to
talk about it next week so we'll do a
video then
now of course i'm on a mountain full of
physicists and astronomers
so maybe i should talk to some of them
but there's just two problems with that
idea
the first is that they are astronomers
so some of them might not be too of a
with the nuances of particle physics but
most of them probably are but there is a
bigger problem
and that is for astronomers
when they come up to a place like this
this is their one chance maybe of the
year maybe of two years to do some
serious observing with world-class
telescopes
that means they spend all their daylight
hours down there sleeping
and then when the sun sets
they all scurry up the mountain
and start their observing
it's a really busy night for them and
i'm guessing the last thing they want to
do is talk to me about higgs bosons
but a lot of them have been talking to
me about various aspects of astronomy
and you're going to see a bunch of those
videos on 60 symbols and my new channel
deep sky videos so stay tuned for that
and in the meantime i'm keeping a blog
here each day with all sorts of pictures
and updates about what's going on i've
put a link to that down the bottom of
this video
and i promise we'll have that higgs
boson video next week
just in case you thought this place
couldn't possibly be any cooler by the
way i'm filming this on a helipad